this is a big year in a lot of ways and
um
one big change for me is that i became
through the course of 2021 something of
a musical genius well i didn't become a
musical genius it was it was more that i
this this i've always been a musical
genius and i that that fact became
public knowledge and uh you know i was
judging entries at the american idol
style competition for the sweet baby
gang anthem
uh we were talking about you know i was
reviewing bts the k-pop band
and uh you know we we watched a lot of
rap videos and that sort of thing so i
wanted to bless you with a couple songs
that i believe
are some of the greatest artistic
creations uh going back to beethoven
before that i mean this these are this
is music that i think transcends music
and now it really puts itself in
competition with and in conversation
with
the great artists of all time you know
um michelangelo da vinci and that sort
of thing so first we have none other
than the great takashi 69 let's watch
i'm very excited today for the chance to
uh listen to and and experience a joint
from my man takashi 69. he is for my
money
one of the most transcendent artists in
the history of western civilization as a
poet i put him on the level of ralph
waldo emerson as a singer he's pavarotti
as a humanitarian his mother teresa
and to think he achieved all of that
despite suffering that horrific accident
where he fell into a giant tie-dye
machine
he actually well he actually looks a
little bit like a bowl of fruity pebbles
come to life or maybe he looks like
something out of a skittles commercial
in hell
but i say all of that in a positive way
it's all part of his genius really now
the song we're going to be experiencing
today is a is a classic it's an oldie
one of the takashi 69 songs that my dad
was listening to back in the day uh it's
not from takashi's newest album which by
the way is available for now for
purchase it's called tattletail
tattletail being a little reference to
the fact that he's a gang member who
sold out his crew to avoid 40 years in
prison
um
lots of people think that you know he
lost street cred for that because he's a
snitch and all that but personally i
think it makes him more relatable
because i can tell you i would totally
flip on my crew to avoid 40 years in
prison wouldn't anyone if i'm going down
the whole level
if i had a crew i mean at all i would
flip on them that's probably why i don't
have one and i'm never gonna get one if
i keep talking like this but if i had a
crew
i would dime them out in a second i
would sit down for the interrogation
the detective would come in and 12
seconds later i will have told them
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
it would be that easy i don't think i've
ever had a friendship that i wouldn't
ruin to avoid a lifetime in prison
but in any case that's just the
background on the artist now let's get
to the song this one is um from way back
in 2017. like i said it's an oldie uh
but but certainly a goodie it's called
cuda
um all right let's uh let's give it a
listen
[Applause]
see can i just say here you know i
appreciate this dichotomy um and already
we're seeing the nuances of takashi 69.
he's got the puppy he's being
affectionate
in the next moment though he's pointing
a gun at your face
it's as if to say yes i can be sensitive
i can appreciate these more pleasant
moments i can stop to smell the roses
but i can also shoot you in the head for
no reason
now a therapist might say that that's a
symptom of a psychopathic personality
disorder but i say no this is just what
it means to be human really we can all
relate to it
on some level
let's uh keep listening
stupid i really do this if i taught it
you know i'll shoot it and i'm gonna
prove it back back don't be moving
stupid oh i'ma use it okay now let's
take a second to reflect on these lyrics
i roll up i'm gonna be booted stupid and
shoot it stupid brought a knife i
brought a ruger stupid i really do this
if i towed it then you know i shoot it
and i'ma prove it back back don't be
moving stupid or i'm gonna use it
now this is the kind of moment in a
takashi song where i know that he gets
me you know he understands where i'm
coming from and i feel a little bit less
alone in the universe because so often i
walk through life feeling frankly booted
and often my wife will say to me honey
you're not booted are you
and then i say
yeah i am booted i am and she'll say
we've talked about this and i'll say
okay well if you if you don't want me to
be booted then get this sucka up out of
my face in that case
so just a normal marital spat that
couples have while walking through bed
bath and beyond on a on a tuesday um
let's get back to the song
[Music]
okay i do have to say uh just just just
one note here probably you don't want to
take a job as a cameraman
on a takashi 69 music video because
you're going to have a lot of people
pointing probably loaded guns right at
you i mean there are a lot of basic gun
safety protocols that are being
disregarded here if you don't know how
to handle one of these things you got no
business carrying one
so that is a concern you know i just
wonder how many cameramen perished
during the making of this video
everybody's dancing jumping up and down
drinking god knows what probably high
and they're literally singing about
killing people and meanwhile they all
have loaded guns and they're pointing it
at the camera that you're holding
i just it seems like a hazardous
combination of factors i hope they have
workman's comp is all
that's really all i'm saying but you
know what however many cameramen died
they didn't die in vain
they died for the sake of true art
if you feel like you're not getting the
respect you deserve in life um well that
might be because you don't have a title
in front of your name that uh causes
people forces people to respect you and
here's here's something that you could
get you could get established titles uh
your very own proclamation like i have
declaring that you are a lord or lady
and you have this and you will gain the
respect you deserve i guarantee you all
you need is this one square foot plot of
land in scotland and established titles
is a project based on historic scottish
custom where landowners are referred to
as lairds or lords and ladies in english
in your title pack which i hold in my
hand here you'll receive at least one
square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate and an official
certificate with a crest your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with which you can see the exact
location of your land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady and you can
get on your credit card you're playing
tickets so this is like a legal name
change i am legally officially
lord matt walsh lord best-selling
children's author matt walsh establish
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to establishtitles.com
matt walsh to save 10 off today remember
to use the discount code matt walsh or
just click the link below that's
matt walsh or just click the link below
well as always and i've listened to that
song so many times i mean every day i
listen to kashi69 but uh it gets to me
every single time truly a work of art
and beautiful
maybe not maybe maybe still though pales
of comparison a little bit
to this masterpiece by nba young boy
well i thought it was time to do another
review of a popular rap song a real
banger you might even say uh and this
one just dropped it's it's that new it's
a nba young boy around
i'm not actually sure where the rapper's
name begins and ends here um
but we'll just call him young boy for
short in any case and i have to say i'm
a little worried that he's taking a
stage name that sort of puts a time
limit on things you know he can't be 46
years old and still called young boy um
it's kind of like i was worried back in
the 90s when lil wayne first came on the
scene that if he has a growth spurt
you'd have to change the name
fortunately he never did so that kind of
worked out anyway let's get to the song
this is uh a
nba young boy around
and let's uh let's watch it together
[Music]
baby
okay just quickly just got to stop it
here i have to say and listen i i i
fully fully admit
and accept that young boy is way cooler
than me orders a magnitude you know but
i just i wonder about this dance move
he's doing this what what what what does
this mean this means nothing
and and this is a and there's no way
that this is okay this you can't go to
the club and do this i've never been to
a club
but i'm pretty sure if i'm at the club
doing this i'd get shot that's that's
the assumption i make
uh and so i'm concerned now i'm
concerned about young boy he looks like
a large flightless bird
um or an escaped mental patient and i'm
concerned that young boy will keep
dancing like this and and no one will
tell him to stop
and so i'm worried about him now that's
that's the feeling that i have but let's
uh let's get back to the song so i
didn't let me hear you say my name
hey
[Music]
okay i got to stop it again
um
and i'm sorry to keep focusing on these
kinds of details but
if we look at the freeze frame here i'm
confused a little bit about what's going
on here you've got young boy in his
garage with a nice car okay i get that
and if i had a car like that i'd spend a
lot of time in my garage too no question
and he's in a swing
all right he put up a swing in his
garage
no problem there's a little weird
but fine but what's happening with the
couch in the back it looks like an
all-white couch that someone's scribbled
all over
um
it looks like my couch is at home
honestly i have four kids
and we actually bought a white couch for
some reason and that's what my kids do
to couches so have my kids been hanging
out with young boys that's what i'm
wondering now if so that's a problem
because i've told them that
they cannot chill in a rapper's crib and
smoke blunts
until they're at least 12 or 13. that's
that's i don't know how many times
i've given that speech
anyway let's get back to let's let's
really get to the meat of this song now
i want i want to hear what young boy
wants to tell me so i'm going to stop
focusing on the frivolous details let's
listen to the message now
playing games
they take out my fashion
[Music]
[Music]
this is where young boy
is bringing to the surface many of his
deepest
fears and hopes anxieties
exposing his very soul to the world
exposing
so many other things especially with his
pants pulled down that far
so listen to what he says here
uh hey check out my fashion strapped
inside my jacket
i just said a prayer for bad bad say
let's go get active
geek and when they cash in
i just love the top down
show them the massive
i pull up freshest
i look like a manic dope inside my coat
got me so dumb
that i might need a nanny
let's focus on just those last two lines
again because he says i pull up freshest
i look like a manic dope inside my coat
got me so dumb that i might need a nanny
so there's something almost freudian
going on here i feel like i can tell
that young boy has been studying some of
the early 20th century psychoanalysts
applying their insights to his own life
here he is yearning for the maternal you
know he says i need a nanny i need a
mother figure a caretaker
this world's a great burden for me i
feel
out of place vulnerable
yet at the same time he realizes that
he's fresh you know he's even fresh
and and this is his recognition of his
own innocence and this is really
fascinating young boy here is exploring
the great tension of youth um that is
the young will cling to their innocence
to their childhood while at the same
time desiring the very freedom and
independence that will lead ultimately
to their corruption and notice the
insecurity too because he says dope
inside my coat so he what does he say he
feels like a dope when he wears his coat
uh maybe it's it's a few sizes too big
it doesn't think it looks good is what
he's trying to say
and these are the concerns
of youth childlike
concerns and maybe that's what the swing
is all about because the swing and and
the car so you see the disparity between
the desires of youth frivolity and play
represented by the swing
against the desires of adulthood
materialism greed represented by the car
and behind him yes behind him is is the
couch covered in scribbles
and this represents confusion
it's his it's his internal struggle the
war between the two competing
psychological forces just stunning and
this is absolutely stunning you know i
don't know why we have to take these two
great artists
who create
musical masterpieces and put them up
against each other i don't know why we
can't just enjoy them but if we have to
name a winner then i think
uh with all due respect to takashi 69
who is who is owed nothing but respect
of course
um and is not only a great artist but
but truly a gentleman and a scholar but
even so i think nba young boy
is the
the greatest musical genius of them all
i would say